they are ready and waiting in a blip
City for they think is the inevitable
after Homs these people fear their next
on the regime's hit list here the rebel
flag flies in the city center but the
area's surrounded by regime tanks and
military vehicles at the moment the
tanks are outside the city and
ever-present
intimidation it Libs citizens believe
it's only a matter of time before they
move in an attack and they have their
own army here we are human we are not an
animal
Kira's like an animal first of all we
are just a human we ask for freedom and
we can't have it unless we get a river
of up lots in our country this is
impossible the UN or any one do to help
you humanity at least send us miracle
food something to diesel you we have
known diesel in a fuel in this city for
a week we are afraid in the front
mascaras aleksa them are scary in homes
here they live in homes built for escape
if the soldiers arrive there's a
labyrinth of alleyways and holes
connecting the houses with hidden steps
leading to rooftops from where they can
run jump and hide for those mourning
their dead this struggle to have a voice
has already cost dear the family here
has lost their son he was just 14 years
old
very criminal 11 malls talk people
Syrian I don't like because very
criminal in the basement of houses
across it Lib province they plot and
plan protests uploading pictures of
demonstrations as well as messages of
revolution they're able by using the odd
satellite transmitter which has been
smuggled across the border because most
communications here have been cut we
must show the world our work we take a
video for everything we see every
imagery every injuries every arrested so
morale continues to be high here despite
what appears to be mounting odds against
them they're still getting defectors
from the Assad army but so far nowhere
near enough to really take on the
president
Alex Crawford Sky News ed Lib city Syria